oh one night my best friend called me
and said hey Natalie did you heard about
uh traceab they look for a missing
person
it's hackers I said what so I wrote a
email to uh Robert sales I said uh can
you help me and he said yes
Natalie's father is listed among several
other missing people the contestants are
looking for he's been missing for over
30 years so those are going to be tough
and you may get very little information
on them at the end of the day but I
think any little bit that we get that we
can submit to law enforcement could help
after two days the team finds no new
information on Natalie's father
but groups like Trace Labs mean you
don't have to search on your own he
still listed and contestants are still
looking for any data they can find
sharing that burden for even a day or
two could make all the difference in the
world
[Music]